hello lovely people and happy
Valentine's Day to you now I was
thinking to myself what might make a
great Valentine's Day feature greatest
videogame couples most romantic gaming
moments or maybe just the weirdest
eating simulation games well I picked
the last one so strap yourself in for
some strange you might want to hit that
subscribe button so you can catch a
slightly less odd video once you're done
with this one
all of these dating Sims have similar
game mechanics there are essentially
visual novels that let you make choices
in dialogue or narrative branches at
various points in the story we'll start
with the dating sim on this list that
I'm betting you have heard of yep it's
the one with the pigeons in how to fool
my friend you're a human but you go to a
school populated entirely by
anthropomorphic birds some of whom
totally fancy you in your off time you
live in a cave in the wilderness and
it's also the year 2188 which is
hilarious not only a you in the future
but it's also the post apocalypse as a
mutated bird flu virus nearly wiped out
mankind
long story short Birds got smart but the
meat of the game has you choosing
between eight potential avian love
interests who range from a mysterious
sexy bookish dove to a super popular and
flirty fantail pigeon still a better
love story than Fifty Shades of Grey
moving right along if birds aren't
really a thing maybe you'd prefer to get
a little prehistoric Jurassic heart is
not only a dinosaur game it's a dinosaur
game that encourages you to try and date
your classmates Tyra who happens to be a
Tyrannosaurus Rex when Tyra drops is
ukulele at a performance you can try to
buy him a new one which might lead to a
date in the park and a tragic tale of
how hot it is for a Tyrannosaurus to
play the ukulele
PACA plus kicks off like your average
schoolyard romance your psyche Kazuma
you have a good life awesome pals and a
sweet girlfriend called azuma Hikari
unfortunately one visit to our packer
Kingdom later and you awake to find
old friend is now an alpaca yeah mama
just like in the movie shallow hell no
one seems to see Yukari as an alpaca
except for you so you'll need to sort
out what's going on and try to make
peace with the fact that you are now
dating a fuzzy four-legged animal if all
of that seems pretty damn
run-of-the-mill to you and you're
thinking you said this would be
seriously weird I came here for the
weird let me talk to you about the
dating sim where you date a brother not
the incest kind the printer kind or is
the English translation on the game puts
it bra man personally printers have only
brought me anger and pain but if you
have a particular fondness for computing
peripheral you can try and make a go of
it with this printer who has a knack for
sport in the game brother falls in love
I can't think of an ink cartridge joke
that isn't too gross for game spots so
let's do the next game finally we've got
to mark save the earth love story a
beautiful goddess of love descends to
earth to find romance awesome all good
so far but as is the case in these sorts
of Sims there's a twist
unfortunately Evian left her body back
in heaven so you'll be romancing a
disembodied head in a flower pot you can
still interact with her head if you feel
so inclined and all your interactions
will alter her feelings for you and her
mood which weirdly drastically changes
the art style that really is just the
tip of the weird iceberg the Internet is
also replete with dating Sims that
feature Team Fortress 2 characters five
nights at Freddy's monsters and John
Cena if you have any weird dating Sims
to add pop them in the comments give
this video a like for love day if you
like and I'll let you get back to your
regularly scheduled gaming programming
you
[Music]